David last time we were talking about
one of Luke's parables the parable of a
banquet and now we're still in that
grand section of the gospel where of
Jesus is moving on to Jerusalem and in
chapter 15 he tells more power balls 15
and 16 really a rich with parabolic
stuff and chapter 15 seems to focus on
the theme of Lost and Found all right it
does and it gives us at the end the
parable of they the prodigal son so
called tell us a little bit about that
theme and about how you read the that
that really striking parable great I
think Luke sets up the theme by giving
us the three parables in a row whether
Jesus told them in this order at the
same time we'll never know but with Luke
the whole thing begin with Pharisees
grumbling about the fact that Jesus is
hanging out with tax collectors and
sinners and Jesus responds to them
something we've seen before is not
simply to turn around and say you silly
people here's what I'm doing is to tell
three stories and in each of the three
stories something very precious is lost
and is found again and the person who
finds it rejoices and I think what what
Jesus is in Luke's context I think what
Jesus is telling the scribes and
Pharisees is that they too ought to join
in God's joy at the fact that those who
have apparently been excluded from God's
family are now welcomed into gods family
as the sheep is found as the coin is
found as the Sun is found som is found
having said that it seems to me that one
reason people love the story of the
prodigal son is that it's not just the
story the prodigal son it's the story of
three major players the father and two
sons and that the power of the story is
that its meaning depends kind of on
where you put yourself in that story and
then one can put themselves in different
places with a great power this came home
to me years ago and in my first years of
being a pastor when I preached as I
frequently did on the first two-thirds
of the story where the son comes home
and the father welcomes them and
everybody rejoices and then basically
sat down and said amen and rejoice in
the fact that all those of us who were
cinema Baptist you know sinners welcomed
home much rejoicing in heaven
penguin time and one of the pillars of
the church appropriately one of the
pillars of the church said to me you
know this the elder son always gets
short shrift said I have always been an
elder son I never wandered far from home
theologically physically morally I have
a pillar of this church I give regularly
for my sake and maybe for God's sake
talk about the older brother too and
ever since I've tried to pay attention
to the tree and they're just a few
things that struck you about the store
this story and that I'd love to hear a
response to it that it is a rich story
and like which stories it has different
meanings and some of the things that's
try to be one you already talked about
it's open-ended we have no idea whether
the whether the elder brother ever comes
in for all eternity is out there in the
fields trying to make up his mind that's
a powerful storytelling technique but I
think one reason we love this story is
we don't know how it's resolved in Jesus
doesn't tell us what we're supposed to
do about it so it's not just an example
story is something richer than that I
love the fact that the father goes out
twice not just once that's what my
pillar of the church friend was telling
me that that the father gets off the
porch once and welcomes the Sun but he
also goes out to seek the lost found one
I mean interestingly in some ways the
one who's most lost is the what it
thinks he's found and the father goes
out to tell him that too I think it's
very powerful and and when the when the
elder brother says this your son has
come back and the father says your
brother this isn't just my son fellow
this is your brother it's a it's just a
story whose power lingers with us and
lots of people if many people have
thought that if there's a parable that
kind of tells the Gospel story this is
that story that Jesus Christ is God's
running down the road to welcome us home
those are marvelous insights and I agree
with everything you've said that let me
just add a couple of other little
perspectives on girl and I think we have
a tendency to alaga rise the story of
the the prodigal son and think of the
father as a kind of cipher for God yeah
and in some ways that the Luclin context
in Chapter 15 gives us a ground for
doing that because the other two stories
they especially a parable of they the
lost sheep is
oh god like oh god now yeah yeah but
I've often ask people when i'm teaching
this this parable to think about what
we've seen in some other cases insert
yourself and a parable in a way
different from what you have usually
done absolutely and think of the father
or not as a cipher for God but as a
cipher for you yeah and they think of
yourself being confronted with a really
difficult choice it could be a personal
choice of alienating someone you love
nice or it could be another cost of
discipleship store i think the father in
some ways is being called to the
compassion that Luke is preaching all
the way through and it's going to cost
him that'll preach yeah I'll preach it
you all know if the best illustration of
the claim I come due time time again
which is that the parables are not unify
seated they're both invested and one of
the best ways to get the different
angles on it is to is to put yourself in
different places just a really quick
aside one of the three or four sermons
that I've preached that I got in great
trouble over and I think this is a sign
of the weakness of my preaching you're
preaching right you should probably be
in trouble most of the time but I what I
still think was a fairly clever trick
which is I made them all female I made
the mother an invalid mother the elder
brother that remember the family who
stays at home and the younger said the
younger sister was the one who wanted
out and lived the high life and came
back and the mother at the danger of
neglecting the elder sister runs out to
welcome the one who was pretty much
neglected her everybody got mad
everybody got mad at the mother when you
change the gender because the family
dynamic came clearer I think then it is
kind of a lager eyes God than we done
all the time I think one does have to
think hard about it interesting no I've
already alluded the possibility that
there's a kind of salvation historical
reading of the story too and then again
that's something that were invited to to
do because of the Lucan context here in
chapter 15 Jesus in confrontation with
the described on the Pharisees the tax
collectors and sinners are coming to
your the Pharisees and scribes grumbling
right yeah so we have that that tensions
that grumbling becomes almost like the
older brother says that's right that's
right
you're welcome invited by group to see
the the opposition to this gospel of
compassion in the form of the Jewish
leadership and that then ties into the
theme that we will run through acts if
they at the rejection of the Christian
message by Jewish leadership and the
open-endedness of Acts Paul preaching in
Rome the Jews the Jewish leadership of
Rome listening to him respectfully so
they going to come in are they not I
think the same old what evidence is
there in acts as we haven't what will
you do how will you come in now the
other thing that strikes me is that we
now follow this was another parable
which if this is the most beloved I'd
say the next one is the most befuddling
parable in all the Gospels in some ways
about the steward and and the steward
does the same thing that the younger
brother does that he that is he he
squanders things and it's exactly the
same Greek word that the younger son
squanders his inheritance and the
steward squanders the responsibility his
master's given him and I it just seemed
this strikes me just so the audience
will remember what what goes on here
that having essentially begun to cheat
his master he then apparently teaches
master again by writing down the debts
that are owed and when the master
returns the bastard commands them is as
nicely done fellow you're cleverer than
I and therefore i'm not going to fire
you very strange for a gospel that's
concerned with mercy and with economic
justice what's going on you think gee I
wish I do I have some ideas and I'll the
other with you in a minute but it's
clear that Luke is a little baffled by
this storage area and it's just a tad
open-ended that is the master doesn't
fire him but he doesn't say he can stay
as true and that the master doesn't seem
to quite know what to do with this guy
he's kind of kind of caught in a bind
and I'm going to suggest why in a minute
Luke I think is a little baffled by what
this what this story is all about it's
not quite a reversal store it's not
quite a compassion story a non-example
store not an example story in the way in
which the prodigal son can be taken at
one level it is a story about money and
it's appropriate use and so Luke after
the story is told in Luke 16 9 gives us
a bunch of sayings all of which have to
do
with appropriate use of wealth one of
his major concerns and you know at the
heart of that is at the concluding one
you cannot serve God and Mammon Oh God
and wealth right so that's an important
element of loop but that's not exactly
what the story says so Lucas is really
struggling to find some meaning in this
story I think the the dynamics of the
story hinge upon what they the steward
is doing and sometimes he's called the
dishonest joto manager sometimes the
shrewd or a prudent steward or manager
and exactly how he is shrewd is I think
the crucial issue here what it does is
make a path for himself with the the
folk who have debts to the oyster and he
cooks the books in some way or other and
the question is why doesn't the master
haul him today Clank for cooking the
books again once interesting solution
and that a scholar in the UK proposed
was that what the what the steward is
doing is work to rule that is he's
cutting down the interest that would be
owed to the master right out of which
his own profits would come and so
there's no skin off the Masters nose
because he's giving up his own profits
and at the same time he's abiding by the
letter of Torah I can't take it I
disagree so the master can't do anything
else because he's being so faithful
that's not a sneaky way that's right
yeah yeah it's an interesting solution
why it is the master can only say good
job guy yeah you've got me yeah but it's
interesting to think about that as a
story that Jesus would tell that you
might be able to abide by everything
that I'm telling you and at the same
time abide by Torah in a way radically
different way yeah so it's analogous in
some ways to what Matthew does in the
Sermon on the Mount I've told you that
but I'm so even though you would do even
more do something differently yeah I my
old line on which I discovered in
getting ready for our conversation today
is an old familiar what much discarded
by all the people we read is that this
is one of those kind of stories where
Jesus says
just as this man was ready before the
crisis so you need to be ready before
the crisis of God's kingdom I still
think back in the Ministry of Jesus they
may be something to that I don't think
Luke reads it that way I think it's some
kind of interesting but as you point out
Luke is a little bit like those
preachers who can't quite figure out
where to end a servant or the political
speech right everything wonderful place
to stop sit down be quiet and here's
another thing and here's another thought
last thing on our conversation today
help help me a little bit think about
when we're when we are reading and
interpreting these parables of both
prodigal son on this one we've made a
kind of interesting move between what we
pretty sure Luke is doing with us
however confusedly and what we think the
parable may have been like before Luke
got a hold of it how do you as an
interpreter of Scripture play those off
against each others at our job to read
the way Lou credit or to say okay in
some earlier version this was even more
interesting for the following reason
yeah well in some cases were forced to
speculate on that I think by the fact
that we have different versions of the
parables of different Gospels and we
have an example for instance in the
parable of the lost sheep which Matthew
takes as a parable an example story for
caring for they the littlest the little
golden that were the congregation yeah
whereas Luke takes it as an example
story for repentance and forgiveness
explicitly in Luke 15 7 yeah so in some
cases were kind of forced to think about
the difference between the gospel
context and what might have been in the
source material I think here in the case
of Luke 16 were forced in that direction
by the discrepancy between the the logic
of the story which is a little opaque to
us and all of these marvels all those
facts are wrong whatever like whatever
those are they might be it so my hunch
is that we have here a really
interesting story that Jesus himself
told and Luke didn't quite know what to
make of it and so that liber8 sus a
little bit to play with that collective
and we've already seen how playing with
these stories which I think were invited
to do as interpreters of a at the
scripture it can yield the meaning and I
think we have the option to do that here
to whether or not we get back to the
authentic but there are real
possibilities that story provides thanks